all right
good morning millennials welcome to the
morning toast welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome to the morning toast bum
bum hope everyone's having an amazing
day happy thursday welcome to the show
hey jax how you doing i'm doing great
considering it's a thursday that for us
feels like a friday because it's our
last show of the week which is just so
spectacular though i really did not
sleep well last night like in fact i
slept quite poorly
i was kept up by my heartburn
it was so bad that just can't happen
again i had a similar experience except
the opposite i slept so great knowing
that in a mere 12 hours i was seeing
taylor taylor gotta get down on calor
that's right for the first time since
they moved i am going to visit olivia
and zach and most importantly her royal
canis and honestly i don't think i've
been this like like
you know how like okay when we were kids
you would be like sleeping the night
before camp and like you just couldn't
think about anything other than camp and
all the fun you were going to have of
course that's how i've been feeling ever
since i booked this flight wow that's
beautiful
not to rub it in because i know you
can't travel but like i'm so excited
give her my love please i i bestowed a
gift for you to bring to her and just
let her know her auntie loves her and
i'm always thinking of her i will let
her know her auntie says hello sends her
best wishes um and i hope you have a
great weekend you know like you deserve
it no i'm so excited like me and kayla
nonstop like love and kisses and hugs
and oh god i'm just praying
i'm literally gonna suffocate her i'm
gonna smother her with my love okay well
while you're doing that bru and i are
having a traditional fall weekend fall
vibes
we're going up you know the the
northeast
border we're going to vermont so it's
extremely autumnal so you've got to make
some chili already working on it i have
to get the meat today
i guess i'm not really doing like a
chilly weekend i guess i'll have to eat
like barbecue and stuff oh so good also
good uh
and yeah it's gonna be fun i'm excited
for some reading some chilling and just
brew because he's never experienced
proper fall vibes because we're coming
up on the one one-year anniversary of
brew coming into my life wow when is
bruce birthday date of birth august 15th
we celebrated that remember everyone
right
we had a big party brew got like so
drunk it was crazy
i don't know the exact date that we got
him but it's in my time hop but it's now
and
it's coming up it's in like two three
weeks and just thinking about what brew
has brought to my life in the last year
it's overwhelming it is and it can't be
understated and to
to think there was ever a world without
brew for me
that's and that if i didn't act
in quickly
and
decisively brew might have never entered
into my world that's the kind of
chilling thing about becoming a mother
is that like you think of you know the
time in your life before your children
existed bb before brew bt before digs oh
i always do stunning i mean so yesterday
jackie and i recorded one of my favorite
patreon episodes to date okay guys this
patreon episode okay zach is still
asking me to send it to him okay me and
ben listen to it last night before bed
so when he asked me to send it to him i
was like let me listen to it from his
pov you know see what he would think and
it was so nice by the way i was like so
hard on myself i don't know what's so
nice
no but i felt i was very
equitable
and i had you think it was an equitable
division of the assets i do and i would
have no problem sending it to him and i
probably will send it him though he
still probably won't listen so me and
ben listened before bed and
first of all he wasn't really upset with
anything i said he was like laughing and
then he was like gaslighting me like no
you do that i'm like okay sure sure jen
um but then it definitely put like a
negative just like
air like in the atmosphere because of
course we fought before bed
like about something totally different
but like i think we just like
fighting mode yeah and honestly i just
wouldn't recommend listening to the
podcast for those who don't know what's
a podcast all about like the most
annoying things your significant others
do i just wouldn't recommend it
listening listening to it together
okay because if we are going to listen
to it i'm going to send it to him he
probably won't listen to it like maybe
we would listen to it in the car because
we have a long drive yeah but
you're saying that we shouldn't
yeah i'm gonna say no
okay we'll see it actually sounds like
something like fun to do in the car want
to listen to this fabulous episode this
is going to be a fabulous well because
then
he'll hear this and be like i want to
listen to the patreon right don't listen
to this episode no but the patron is so
good so basically everybody uh toasters
like sent in the things that their
husbands do that annoy them most and we
read a lot of them but there was over
700 comments we could not get to all of
them we read your guys's qualms and then
we shared if we experienced this or not
and you know cited some personal
examples some maybe conflict resolution
things that have worked for us yeah
there wasn't much of that no there was
not much of that but if any yeah
it was nice to see but the moral of the
story is that we all marry the same
person and the moral of the story is
that like this might have been i think
in my opinion like one of our best
months of patreon content ever because
we had the makeup tutorial we had the
mukbang we had the
significant others what were the first
two we had olivia sharing her news oh my
god that was only a month ago i know
that feels like forever ago yeah and
then we had the podcast that we did
about judaism around the um jewish
holidays you know what like truly a
well-rounded month of content for only
7.99 head over to patreon.com it's worth
it it's worth it support your favorite
girls and you know we're always
switching things up having fun over
there so if you want extra content to
get you through the day
patreon.com morning toast we have an
amazing show for you guys today it's
thursday which means we've got our real
housewives of beverly hills recap i also
watched kathy and kyle and watch
rapping's live me too and i just have a
lot of feelings like about last night's
episode not that it was the most
you know drama filled but i felt i felt
as though it was very telling of a lot
of things okay cool and i would like to
dive into that and we also just gonna
deliver the fast five stories because
the world never stops turning and
neither do we
exactly so i think without further ado
it is time for the past life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode of the morning toast
is brought to you by hawthorne as we've
all been getting back to our normal
normal routines it's time to introduce
the men in your life to a new routine
personal care taking care of your skin
might be second nature but creating his
routine you'll need something that's
easy customized and smells good and you
know this is very appropriate
considering we spent the entire day
yesterday complaining about the things
that our
husbands and boyfriends do um and not
taking care of their skin is one of them
like is it on me to be your facialist
and like literally pop all your
blackheads it is but it shouldn't be
if you want to help elevate the men in
your life to look feel and smell their
best the easiest way to the easiest way
is to give them a routine tailored
specifically to their needs from
hawthorne a premium grooming brand that
is designed to create personal care
products and routines for men that fit
their unique profile they focus on skin
and hair products plus cologne and they
work to address their biggest concerns
so basically you just have to take the
quiz on hawthorne and they'll ask things
like
how his skin texture is is his skin dry
does he use a cleanser um it was
actually really easy and
is so lazy i did do it for him and i
knew most of the answers because i'm a
very educated wife um they also take the
risk out of out of it by gifting you um
free shipping on your order and return
so if the man in your life doesn't like
the products hawthorne will either even
retailer them based on their feedback so
take the quiz today and get the men in
your life started on their new routine
by going to hawthorne.co
that's h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o
hawthorne dot co slash gift and using
promo code toast you get 10 off your
first hawthorne order at
hawthorne.com gift promo code toast
that's hawthorne.com
gift promo code toast thank you claudia
just really quickly i ran into um every
single housewife of new jersey last
night and it was just a pleasure i
missed those gals yeah i saw margaret
melissa
and joe
margaret and joe and jackie
goldschneider who was like sipping on a
spritz and she was loving it she was
like these are the best oh my god that's
so awesome jackie goldschner approved
wow you love to hear it you do love to
hear it okay let's get into the stories
our first story is the big story of the
day britney spears's father jamie spears
has been immediately suspended from her
conservatorship
britney spears's father has been ousted
from her conservatorship following a law
a drawn-out legal battle that has
persisted since the pop star was placed
under the court-ordered arrangement in
2008. judge brenda perry ruled that
spears's father will no longer serve as
the conservator of his daughter's estate
immediately removing him from control of
her finances the judge said i believe
that the suspension is in the best
interests of the conservative the
situation currently is untenable a
hearing was set for november 12th to
determine whether the conservatorship
will be ended entirely wow so that's the
next
inflection point on this so brittany
just has this like fabulous new big time
magazine editor lawyer who's just like
making things happen like literally
getting more done in the last like few
months then it's been getting done in
the last 10 years i think the next thing
they're trying to do so the person who's
been temporarily well not temporarily
like the new conservators just like an
accountant like as it should be yes um
but jody montgomery is still like in
charge of brittany um not her money but
like she's like her like handler yeah
and that's the next thing they're
tackling like getting rid of jody um and
hopefully that can happen before
november 12th so we have to wait till
november but if they just got this whole
thing like
removed like that would be so crazy yeah
that would this is really a big win i
mean this is what britney has been
asking for so
we love to see it it's a big stride for
the free brittany movement and i also
think i'm sure her new lawyer is
extremely effective but i i have to
imagine that the public
out of cry of free britney has
influenced
some things in this case yeah and
especially because like the free britney
activists are like they don't let one
piece of public record like
paperwork go by unpublished like they
find everything they put it all over
social media and it really felt like for
so long that these
judges and like random people involved
in the um
in the conservatorship like are all
being bribed in some way and like i just
feel like now that the paper trail is
being so like looked at with such a
magnifying glass like they had to just
give it up you know like britney and not
brittany jamie like
bye disgra he's literally disgraced king
and we're just very much looking forward
to justice being served we are and we're
well on our way this is one big step for
brittany one
small step for mankind 100 like this is
so trivial it's like not even like
they're asking for something so
outrageous right but you just love to
see it you do are you ready for our next
story a little drama a little like
mindless drama that you really love to
see between who we actually have two
dramatic stories this is not
the one that you're thinking that's next
okay but drama between lala kent and
ariana maddox oh my god but it's not
it's instagram drama which was like
actually so bizarre okay so okay detail
it for everyone yes so ahead of the
season nine premiere of vanderpump rules
on tuesday lala posted a throwback photo
in lieu of a current one one which
didn't sit well with ariana apparently
the picture she posted featured la la
posing alongside former co-star stassi
and katie along with katie maloney
schwartz and she captioned the picture i
had to with a heart emoji right so for
those who don't understand the
significance she was just the other two
people in the photo have been fired from
the show right but she just wanted to
like you know
she wanted to commemorate i'm sure the
premiere was like hard for them to watch
it i'm sure as a close friend i'm sure
for lala and katie like going back to
the show after their friends had been
fired like probably felt weird you know
and i think like so
lala's
perception of it was like just
commemorating the last you know time and
blah blah like moving into this new era
whereas like first i think she was like
like we're doing the show even though
like they fired our friends but like i
still love and respect my friends and
here they are yeah and i think with with
ariana maybe other people was like we're
supposed to be promoting our new show
and like this is what you're doing right
so ariana commented i love you all but i
guess i'm just confused what this post
is supposed to be giving on the night of
our premiere are you living in the past
or are you ready for the future of the
show to me this comment like they
clearly have a chip on their shoulder
about the fact that this is a new
iteration of the show and after seeing
the first episode a lesser version of it
and we know why still have the chip
right i think that she
you know
and it the show is now focused more like
on her and some of the other people who
maybe were like faded to the background
a little yeah they they weren't like the
mainstays every season so i think it
feels like an attack on you know this
new show well also like what we were
saying yesterday when we recap this new
version of the show is that like it's
very much seeming like it's going to be
the tom and ariana show and like the tom
and tom show which therefore makes it
like tom ariana katie and i think that
like
the fact that lala posted
something kind of
praising the old guard as opposed to the
new guard which really is tom katie tom
and ariana um i think that probably
bothered ariana and like motivated her
to post this like if it wasn't
if it wasn't
now being portrayed as like very much
surrounding around tom and tom i don't
know if ariana would have been offended
but she's like it's supposed to be about
me now like right i mean but katie's in
the picture and she's fine with yeah the
support well of course
but so then lala deleted the picture
saying because someone was affected
right so did you leave the picture and
then somebody wrote like a q a like did
you delete that picture and she did an
instagram story i believe she had her
middle finger up and she was like yeah
because someone was affected
but then she posted it again and said um
i had to again and then
and then she added something to the
caption yeah but i forgot what it was
and it's not here so this is just like
mindless drama but it is nice to know
that like this drama we're seeing in the
show like lala or sorry i like actually
is real yeah and it doesn't get resolved
and it's like they're clearly not not on
speaking terms because ariana started
her comment like i love you all
but there's this tension no ariana has
this chip on her shoulder that was the
perfect way of saying it but i think
that the whole
cast probably does but not for lala
because whether this new show succeeds
or not is whatever but for like ariana
tom everyone the schwartz is no it's
like if this show doesn't succeed then
this new bar that we're opening doesn't
succeed like it's so much deeper for
them whereas for lala it's their job
that she likes she has other jobs no but
also like lala
has a husband who has a good amount of
wealth whereas like all these people on
the show who have built lives around the
show had babies but
bought houses like their income is
dependent on the show so like not only
if the show doesn't succeed like they
have this new bar but it's also their
livelihood yeah but also i mean yes it's
nice that lala you know can be provided
for from her man but she has other
businesses like 100 she wrote a book she
has a podcast she has a beauty company
so she's someone who's like
other ventures don't revolve completely
around the show no but that's like so
now when you look at all the people who
don't
currently film the show like stassi
is fine financially like she her even
though her podcast was canceled like she
is in the process of building it back up
but then it's like when you look at
jackson britney who's like both of them
were so dependent on the show like i
don't know what they're going to do like
i don't know how long the vanderpump
money lasts yeah or what else they have
um you know because they have they were
in some like businesses like what
happened with the landscape beer cheese
yeah
so i don't know and jack jack's had done
for maybe an interview or even when he
was just filming saying that he was like
an early investor in like a really big
weed farm in california which if that's
true then i'm not worried me too
okay good to know like kristen has
what's her james may yeah like they all
did stuff
stuff but i think some people's stuff is
stronger than other people's stuff
obviously to put it kindly very kindly
are you ready for our next story which
is some more
drama some more instagram drama actually
love i literally love instagram drama
heather mcdonald is hitting back at
chrissy teigen saying quote i do not
hate anyone
so heather mcdonald's is embroiled in um
this psychotic scandal chrissy tegan and
it all started a few days ago when
chrissy posted
a picture of herself um and her eyes are
closed other than that like she looks
you know pretty
i do think the timeline of this entire
story is essential
to understanding it yes and you know
what i'm just going to go straight to
the story to the instagrams because i
want to read the captions for you
verbatim so that everybody so that we
all can make up our own minds about this
one and while jackie does this this
heather mcdonald drama is brought to you
by olive in june the best mayonnaise
system out there if you're looking for
the answer to salon perfect nails at
home the olive and june polish lasts
seven days and does not chip and with
their money system each at-home manicure
comes out to just two dollars and we
have a special code so just make sure to
listen for it if your biggest issue is
not being able to do your own nails and
having your polished chip not having the
right supplies the olive and june manic
system has everything you need first of
all they offer the most beautiful
polishes that are designed to last over
seven days the entire manny system comes
with all the things you would need like
cuticle oil nail file just all the
things you never have but are always in
need of
and olive and june has just got you
covered um i've been doing my nails with
olive and june since i actually did mine
this was like two weeks ago but um since
the
pandemic it's been just like a true
lifesaver it's only five steps um and
they have this fabulous little item that
if you have like a shaky hand when
you're doing your own nails and it's
really hard to do it's a silicone cap
grip yes that you put on top of their
nail polish bottles and it really just
steadies the entire
process it's called a poppy and it's
their patented brush handle makes it
easy to paint both of your hands so if
you're looking for your new nail life
get 20 off your first manning system
when you use promo code toast at
oliveinjune.com we're done with
expensive bad manicures this is the new
us 20 off your first manny system using
promo code toast at
oliveinjune.com you for that claudia
okay from the top the other day chrissy
teigen posted a photo of herself um
with you know she's in full glam she's
in good lighting she clearly was taking
a series of photos and decided to post
the one with her eyes working where she
was blinking yes she said i really think
you guys are too conditioned to seeing
perfect photos all day because so many
of my comments on any given photo are
why would she post this or i love you
girl but this is not flattering to which
i say who cares a lot of the time makeup
artists and hairstyles we'll ask if
photos are good enough to post and my
reply is always the same i honestly
don't care post whatever i don't know i
just don't care about curating my
instagram to be perfection i'm a mess
i'm chaotic and this shall always
reflect that
okay thank you love sagittarius that's
what you said yes okay so if you know
this story
good but if you don't know the story so
this this was just one post that's all
we had gotten from chrissy that day
nothing else correct correct okay so
then heather mcdonald commented on her
post saying these humble brags of this
of this is an unfiltered picture so say
whatever mean thing you want so people
will actually write nice things since i
act still actually look great is so
three years ago chrissy you know what
was curated your twitter so i'm i just
have to say like that was a very brave
comment and i was fully in agreement
with it like
it is so three years ago like oh i'm so
impersonal
and it's like some people really do go
hard on the real instagram they post
like no makeup and they're showing their
true selves
this photo is not that this she's in
full glam this photo is like not brave
this photo is not not curated it's just
the eyes are closed your eyes are closed
so like so it is like such a lame thing
to do and i actually really like loved
heather calling it out like first of all
chrissy is in this like recovery mode
where she's literally trying to bounce
back from being
declared the world's biggest bullying
like like a [ __ ] on like bullying
children like so that's what she's
currently working through and this is
definitely like a defensive defense
mechanism like i'm so not perfect i'm so
real like you guys like no you're not
like i hate when people do that
especially like jack vanek does it
actually really well like this is me in
a bikini and this is me hunched over in
a bikini like they're those are real
helpful things in my opinion this
picture of chrissy teigen is so lame and
is such like fishing for compliments
it's fishing for compliments and heather
was merely pointing that out and she
posted her comment and this screenshot
to her instagram where she posts a lot
of her comedy yeah and just said i
cannot take it i'm just having one of
those days where i had to point out the
hypocrite on ig i can't be the only one
that can see through this bs
so
then that was it for a little while that
was it for a minute yeah but then
chrissy posted on her instagram i didn't
sleep at all last night as john can
attest i was up sick sobbing as my phone
popped up with the memory of being in
the hospital exactly one year ago losing
our baby so maybe i'm a little sensitive
today but [ __ ] off and most people are
taking that [ __ ] off to heather mean
directed at heather because um
and then she shared that you know this
was the one year to the day of her
having a miscarriage which is so sad and
then the narrative was basically like
heather mcdonald is like bullying
chrissy teigen you know on the
anniversary when like in heather's
defense
nobody knew that it was the anniversary
chrissy posted it after that so i think
that we can like have a lot of sympathy
for chrissy and and
what must be a very difficult
anniversary but also like let's not
you can't blend the two like
the tmz was like
heather mcdonald posted on her instagram
the tmz headline people are just taking
things out of proportion and making it
seem like heather was intentionally
bullying chrissy teigen on a difficult
day for her
um
which it just
was not
so
hold on wait i read it yesterday
whatever i can't find it like all the
articles are basically now there's two
separate events and all the articles are
like making them seem like they're like
that chrissy told heather to [ __ ] off so
right then
and that heather was like attacking
chrissy on this difficult day for her
which when heather did post that comment
we did not know that it was this
particular day right then heather posted
the tmz article saying thanks tmz for
posting such a great photo of me
mid-sentence that one time you stopped
me outside of craigslist the two photos
just you guys you have to look at the
the the photos that they made a collage
of for
like chris is not women supporting other
women look at these photos that is so
mean but that's just like
classic media manipulation you know like
one person looks like the angel one
person looks like the devil oh literally
me and cuba getting junior like cuba
getting junior looking like a stud me
looking like something that fell off a
truck like
[Music]
literally that's [ __ ] e news i'll
never forget tmz everyone was coming for
me showing like every ugly picture of me
and like cuba's like literally like he
just
walked out of a ray of sunshine yeah
like no he looked like a professor with
his glasses on when he's the one who
stuck his finger up my butt without
consent right and can you see like that
just that in general of posting to the
pictures of both people and you're going
to let us know via the picture who you
think is the bad person who's a good
person yeah that's like click bait from
the 90s like that's like putting your
headline all in caps it's so [ __ ] up
we as a society have to stop doing that
yeah no just like post even photos like
rare and righteous photos
that's neither here nor there though so
heather said when chrissy posted the
flattering photo of herself in glam and
a nipped in waist claiming it was in
fact unflattering i merely was pointing
it out that many of us now see the
humble brag attempt and call bs now
since she considers herself a comedian
and was literally a judge on tv of
comedy i was praying that she come up
with some new material for her social
media i do not hate anyone maybe today
chrissy can squeeze the outside of her
thigh and highlight a cellulite dimple
so the world can again remember how real
she is i have chrissy is just a mom
supermodel who actually eats and is
super authentic if you want to hear my
thoughts live come to the irvine improv
on october 1st heather is like milking
this to sell her improv which you gotta
respect the hustle i don't know i just
feel like
i agree with what heather's saying like
it's so lame of chrissy like i'm so real
blah blah but then it's also just like
not fair of the media to be conflating
these two things like they have anything
to do with each other and they don't
yeah and i just feel like you can agree
and like want to critique like christy
tegan out here like fishing for
compliments while also understanding and
being very empathetic and having a lot
of sympathy for like this very difficult
time she went through one year ago
yesterday the two have nothing to do
with each other yes but it's like not
cool of tmz like making it seem like
heather intentionally woke up knew it
was the anniversary of something
difficult for chrissy tegan and decided
to attack her like that's not what it is
no not at all but then you told me that
this has become like such a so then
heather posted on instagram today uh
there's a page six article basically
recapping this idiocy and then this was
heather's caption which is crazy up now
on juicy scoop she did a podcast about
it tmz and others reported on why
christy tegan told me to [ __ ] off i tell
you the whole juicy scoop here did kyle
oh
oh whatever so
she she's promoting her podcast and then
she says i was booked for three days on
ease nightly pop but was then fired
after one day because of this drama i
don't know i have to listen to the
podcast but that's what it seems like i
would have to imagine it's because of
this what else could it be even though
like wouldn't they want like right from
the horse's mouth i don't know but that
is that's really crazy
instagram drama i'm telling you it has
real life repercussions
she probably was so good on nightly pop
and they need to find a co-host for
morgan's maternity leave they've been
like rotating in a lot of people yes i
think it's like you know kind of like an
auditiony time i am she would be a great
heather mcdonald's fan like she's
so funny
and
i agree she would have been great yeah
so anyways that's the latest
and greatest from
instagram from instagram are you ready
for our next story
sure
bachelorette claire crawley reveals i
was abused by a predator priest at a
catholic school
so claire crowley is going on red table
talk oh and in a preview for thursday's
installment that's today so i guess it
comes out today she reveals that she was
mistreated by a priest while attending
catholic school she said i grew up going
to a catholic school and i was the
victim of a predator my parents looked
at catholic priests as they held them on
a pedestal
she said uh her mother is of mexican
descent and she said that faith and
religion run very deep in our family's
roots gloria estefan co-hosted this
episode of red table talk it's called
red table talk the estefans
and so it's not the smiths no
oh that's cool yeah so she said she was
so shocked by claire's revelation she
said how could you not trust a priest
and she explained that the precinct
question was largely perceived as a
counselor at her high school she said my
parents did the best they could and
reached out to the resources they could
at the time and sent me to the priest i
don't think there was any counseling
that was done it was a one-on-one time
to be a predator oh you know the priests
like being predators is like in my
opinion like one of the worst things
like about our society and you know what
i feel like spotlight was such a good
movie but also because like i've never
even met a priest so like
the way it really highlighted how like
some parents have such a hard time even
believing that this stuff happens
because you have so much faith and like
your priests are literally like the most
important people in your life and that
you're leaders like you look up to you
your whole belief system is shattered
and that's not something that's easy to
wrap your head around exactly and it's
so disgusting and it's so upsetting and
this is so sad yeah do you ever watch
the keepers no because
i don't think i would be able to it was
a lot but it was really well done
docuseries true stories about um what
went on in this
catholic school and like the systematic
abuse just and like the
the way it was all orchestrated you know
and how many people were in it it wasn't
just like one person it was it was
really crazy and this story really
reminds me of that um
and once again we just need to be doing
better for our children
100
like
that's just seems to be the moral of the
story every day also like totally
related but not related is that claire
and dale broke up i know like officially
clarendale is over i'm sad i actually am
because you know what like once they
come back together against all odds they
did it and like you know once they broke
up right after the show and everyone was
like oh classic whatever but then they
got back together and i was like you
know what this is it and they were doing
the damn thing and they weren't being
that annoying about it
not at all being kind of like low-key
you only knew about it from like dumois
uh-huh so i was really here for it even
though like i don't follow either of
them and maybe they were being extra on
instagram and i missed it and i'm really
here for claire's happiness me too and
so to know that
it's a no
that just you know made me sad but i'm
glad that her whole season wasn't a
waste because when he broke up like the
next day because it turned out that he
was just like this raging thirst monster
it was like she completely and because
she blew up her show because she really
was just trusting her heart like
that was really sad yeah so at least
that's not the story at least we got
what like a year out of it
more or less yeah yeah her season aired
in like june of last year perfect i
think well i do wish them the best um
also just yet again like
red table talk constantly raising the
bar for every web show out there yes
it's so good sorry who's gloria esteban
she's a singer yeah
she seems like some really great songs
yeah yeah yeah i just don't think like
if i met her i wouldn't recognize her
that's okay but if you heard her song
for sure you would recognize those is
she calling gloria
probably right
gloria when i used to hear that song as
a kid i would be like
claudia claudia yeah we all you're
always on the run now claudia which is
obviously not true
get on your feet and then also what's
good on your feet get uh don't make me
sing get on your feet and also i think
there's a broadway musical about her
called get on your feet
that's cool i still don't think i know
any of her songs
um you do you really do who sings
calling gloria
i'll look it up calling gloria gloria
i don't think she would sing a song
about herself i think she would
um
it's by laura branigan fabulous song
fabulous fabulous song okay but let's
get back to get on your phoenix and they
used to play that like at every batman
sun everyone would be like connie yeah
i'm imagining that maybe i
made that up about get on your feet and
use on your feet
but still and it's based on the lives
and music of 26 time grammy
award-winning husband and wife team
glorio gloria and emilio esta estefan
the musical has a book written by
alexander dinolares jr okay okay and
still what songs does gloria estefan
saying what's on your feet
it's a musical no the song i'm going to
play it okay
no but i don't know like i don't know
well enough to
um
to get you to reel
[Music]
i've never heard this song we're not
gonna be able to monetize
i've never heard this song in my life
never heard the song in my life
yes you it's giving me very much [ __ ]
it's giving me very much to carry
diaries energy
okay
sounds great gotta add it to my playlist
yeah no it's great and check out the
musical and check out red table talk
are you ready for our fifth and final
story it's a little ice cream news and
it's also
the final story
[Music]
[Laughter]
that has become my best part of my part
of your show your show
yes thank you finally someone
recognizing this is my show
um wait just really quickly all this
laughing is giving me a headache so
gotta talk about cove
no two migraines are alike and if you
experience migraines you know the
doctors at cove know this too and they
only treat migraines cove is the world's
leading online migraine clinic
specializing in diagnosing and treating
of all migraines from the comfort of
your own home with only one specialist
per 80 000 migraine sufferers in the u.s
cove is making quality care accessible
and affordable go to withcove.com
complete the online consultation
designed by leading neurologists and
it's as though it's as thorough as an
in-person doctor's visit then a licensed
doctor will review your migraine history
and recommend a treatment plan
customized specifically to your needs
your prescriptions will also be
delivered right to your door which is
just everything of the sort you don't
have to wait for the doctor you don't
wait at the pharmacy um cove is also
really affordable their doctor's fees
and prescriptions are as little or less
than most insurance co-pays and their
prescriptions can start at just ten
dollars a month and with cove you can
have more migraine free days so go to
with cove.com toast for 50 off your
first month of medication and free
two-day shipping that's 50 off your
first month of medication and free
two-day shipping at with cove dot com
slash toast that's w-i-t-h-c-o-v-e
dot com slash
toast you guessed it thank you for that
claudia it's a pleasure
doing business with you and you never
like indulge me i know but i saw that i
just wanted to indulge it doing business
with you
it really is a pleasure doing business
it is it always is i can't my um blazer
looks like a blazer
that's okay i mean i'm very familiar
like i bought this blazer in 2019 that
like peak snatch and i'm wearing it five
months pregnant leave me alone
i
don't believe i said jenny don't ask me
to reach over okay i and it does look
better when i'm standing versus when i'm
sitting i don't believe i said a word
about it i think that you did
our fifth and final story is some
exciting ice cream collaboration news
from one of our favorite brands this is
giving me craft mac and cheese nope okay
take it back i take it back it's coming
to carvel oh hocus pocus shakes
are coming to carvel just in time for
freeforms 31 nights of halloween so this
is a multi-tiered collab hocus pocus
carvel free form and if it wasn't carvel
we would not be talking about it are
they making milkshakes yeah so they have
three shakes inspired
they're so spooky they're inspired by
each of the sanderson sisters this is
these are the three shakes let me know
which one you want to go for and then we
also like have to share like which
sanderson sister do you think you are
i don't [ __ ] know i'm the one from
sister act who's not sarah jessica
parker and who's kathy midler said her
name
i think i'm like kathy najimy's number
one fan no she's she's so talented okay
what are the three flavors winnie's
glorious cake batter so that's bette
midler um it's cake batter ice cream i
[ __ ] love cake batter yeah no it
sounds really good then we have sarah's
chilling churro shake no
okay then we have mary's divine cookies
and cream shake which sounds like fun it
can't go wrong jackie did i not say i'm
sarah jerry's number one fan jackie
what's my favorite flavor of ice cream
where do what what do i always get
vanilla with sprinkles with sambar
smoothie okay not froyo like ice cream i
guess cookies and cream like because did
you not know that no i would not say
that i always get cookies and cream no
you don't oh my gosh these look like all
like cookies and cream by the way i have
been obsessed with cookies and cream
since the day i was born you have always
liked like weird things like mint
chocolate chip and like pistachio that's
a lie i do think mint chocolate chip can
be a delicious treat sometimes i know
yeah if you're warm if you need to brush
your teeth on a warm summer's day but
these days since i have ice cream so
rarely like when i do i splurge i go for
you know
cookies and cream i get two ice creams
usually because i like to
try multiple things but it's usually
cookies and cream with oreo you know
it's like
well cookies and cream just has oil i
know it's like being in the pool and
pouring water on yourself oh you get
extra oreo yeah delicious that's kind of
crazy that's how much i love cookies and
cream where's the best cookies and cream
ice cream you've ever had stayed on the
count of three okay
i think i know what you're gonna say one
two three wins gotta get to kill ones
yeah didn't we go in
newport
did we remember when we got ice cream
that night no
we got ice cream one night i think it
was killing something kind of familiar
right i went on tour to st peter
petersburg florida me and margo were
like eating lunch at some like place and
we looked across the street there was a
kill wins like that's in my memory the
last time we went but you have better
memory than me is there even one in
newport
there's one way to find out google
um and just back really quickly to the
carvel of it all i just i'm really glad
that big networks are fine like car
carvels are going out of business at an
unsettling rate and i'm so glad that
hollywood has decided to put a little of
their energy into saving carvel because
i'm just really sick of people ignoring
the only franchise that matters there's
literally one left in new york like it's
so sad there's more than one but i agree
that they don't get the respect that
they deserve and there used to be way
more than there are now and it's a
dwindling franchise yeah and it's so
american and there is a kill winds in
newport and that's where we went for
sure what night
we remember we went to that early dinner
where we were freezing
it was by the water
and then we were going to walk to the
bars but was also like kind of early so
we went to kilwins to kill some time was
that when dana ordered a tanqueray she
ordered this tanqueray like the whole
trip and i think she stuttered no
because it was the last dinner of the
trip
and then we went to sitting on a round
table
at dinner no we were sitting on a square
table and we were so cold hold on let me
just go through my camera roll what was
i wearing
that i can't this my mouth remember this
was my memory doesn't extend this was
less than a year ago
this was yeah almost a year ago i
remember
the first night
and the restaurant was empty and then
the second night we ate at that like
clam place we went to that other hotel
for rest for dinner other hotel
other hotel i'm going to find a picture
for you i don't this is really bothering
me yeah no offense i've like lived such
a life that i can't even remember like
what's the point i spent all this money
on experiences
and i can't even remember it
did we not take any pictures that night
that doesn't sound let me check my phone
what i'm not letting this go what
time of year it was october 2020.
newport is in rhode island oh it's
actually this coming weekend was the
anniversary no way
no we must have not taken pictures at
dinner
oh here they put two circle t no that
was at a bar
oh my god okay this is not no by the way
it's not interesting for the listeners
it's not interesting for the listeners
think of the listeners no but please
it's really bothering me
okay you can keep talking movies on the
water
in the
marina oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
okay claudia we have to get together
keep going the sooner you finish your
show sooner you can see kayla
that's true
i'm just still looking i'm sorry what
weekend was it imagine you're a podcast
listener no it's so annoying listening
to someone scroll through their phone
okay i'm done
found it
i can't
did we wear these outfits
we were always wearing those outfits
okay whatever i'll let it go thank you
um all right are we done with the past
five stories and did you feel as though
you needed to know them yes and yes and
now we need to recap vanderpump rules
vanderpump rules you know what i meant
pregnancy brain
oh my god um yes we are recapping vanna
from royals a.k.a the real host of
beverly hills which is brought to you by
betterhelp this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp if there is something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
betterhelp is here to assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist where you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
better help is not a crisis line it is
not self-help it is professional therapy
and it's done securely online
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas and their
services available for clients worldwide
here's how it works you log into your
account anytime and you can send a
message to your therapist and in return
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room as you do with traditional
therapy better help is also more
affordable than traditional offline
therapy and financial aid is available
because betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today we also have
a special offer for the morning toast
listeners if you want to get 10 off your
first month go to betterhelp.com
toast
betterhelp.com
toast that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
okay
so before we dive into last night's
moronic circus that was beverly hills
it's worth mentioning that i watched
watch happens live and we were
speculating last week as to whether or
not erica and kyle were on good terms
and they are they're on terms erica kyle
said she spoke to her yesterday and kyle
would not say one bad word about her
last night on watch rap inside which was
so frustrating interesting okay maybe me
when erica said she only had one friend
left maybe that was like a joke no maybe
it was kyle no way her and lisa what
trouble
what happens live did like a poll like
who's so far up right and it was random
reno out of all the women had 70 yeah
okay but last night's episode they
finished this fabulous trip in del mar
like honestly if i ever were to go on a
trip i would need kathy hilton to plan
it because she doesn't overdo it like
she likes to relax so she does like one
activity a day and it's actually a
lovely
schedule and i was just saying like
would love to be
on a trip planned by kathy hilton
but the real crux of the episode was
erica's
actual mood swings like it was so
bizarre first of all she's so rude to
sutton and i'm just like done with
people walking over sudden when she's
the only one acting normal no and she's
such a good friend and i almost forgot
it was once like erica was being like a
little bit human towards sutton and
started crying just because like the
loss she had such a good friend in erica
and i didn't even realize that they were
such close and like how much that meant
to sutton and so just to discard a
friendship doesn't mean nothing to her
and she's just such a good person i'm so
glad that crystal finally realizes that
she's not the villain in this cast like
no and we knew that when crystal was
coming for her and it's like it just
takes everyone like a minute a minute to
understand sutton but i'm so glad she's
off of that
uh
hill because a hundred percent because
also i was loving crystal's energy last
night and i'm like you just need to make
up a sun and i had even forgotten that
they like were not close so the fact
that crystal said something and really
put this thing to bed made me really
love crystal after like a great episode
for her like buying everyone bottles of
wine it was a good episode for crystal
it really was but the bar is pretty low
because she just it's like in in past
episodes she's been so wrong it's as if
she's not even there sometimes a hundred
percent
but
here's the thing like
sutton is like so on point especially in
her confessionals like when erica's
sitting around talking about how like
she's been through so much and she's
just being like victim victim victim
sutton is just giving me everything in
her confessionals and she's right like
all these women are just drinking the
kool-aid and they're so far up erica's
ass are like afraid to say one thing
that'll just
even remotely make her
like even the tiniest bit upset and it's
like so frustrating to sit around and
watch that but then like sudden and
maybe it's just like the type of person
she is like she's really strong in her
confessionals and then like when erica
and her were like on the
doc doc eric was like i want to
apologize oh you don't have to apologize
like yeah come on like she literally was
so [ __ ] nasty to you and you didn't
even do anything like you're out here
like making exceptions yeah no i agree
it makes me also feel like maybe
something has happened in between the
filming and the confessional taping
because
they both are yes sutton's coming off
stronger and erica in her blue outfit is
the literal like devil definitely she's
being so mean the meanest person ever so
i think we just need a little more
context there but i agree and you know
what i can honestly like yes we want a
perfect housewife who's bringing the
same energy the confessionals as they
are to the group but i can actually
relate to feeling something and then you
know the way that you bring it to the
public you do all of a sudden you know
lose your voice a little bit because
it's [ __ ] human nature 100 and erica
is a scary person so
even though it's not perfect housewife
behavior
it happens in real life all the time for
me the actual low point of the episode
was erica talking to kyle after playing
pickleball and was like you know i told
my lawyers i don't want a dollar and
they told me that that was the most
courageous thing they ever heard well
now that she didn't want a dollar she
doesn't expect a dollar right that's not
courageous that just seems like you
understand the
the board no but not only that like
we're supposed to applaud your courage
because if there's any money left it
should go to widows and orphans and not
a woman who spent forty thousand dollars
a month on glam like that doesn't make
you courageous at all actually no and
she's just exp like she just her last
name was a full display of her acting
like just trying to like garner sympathy
not be made this villain try and be like
a little nicer like to set and she was
like on this like weird press tour last
last night's episode that i don't think
lasts very long
yeah it clearly doesn't last till next
week i think for erica the best case
scenario in this situation is that she
comes out of the pres the court
proceedings unscathed in terms of like
her
role guilty
fraud
but that she will get enough she will
get no money from tom's estate like she
won't but that she will
be clear enough to continue working in
the way that she is now and she can live
off of that money and like how is she
still paying for glam i mean i think she
makes a lot of money from the show yeah
and she i i'm sure she like had a good
personal savings from you know she had
great collabs like her book was new york
times bestseller she had a collab with
beauty blender like she was everywhere
for a long time like i hope she saves
some of that money too but i think she
just wants to be able to do that again
yeah and i think that's so realistic if
she doesn't have any like legal
implications right so she but the whole
divorce thing is so weird because she's
like the only person on earth who still
cares about tom
and like the way that she speaks about
people in his life who don't want to be
associated with him is so delusional
like she thinks it's disgusting of
people who you know don't want to be
associated with time don't want to help
him don't want to take care of him like
would you he's a monster
yeah i'm not talking about his family
like she's like his friends like who he
helped get and oh you know he's done so
much good and and what about that okay
if you've done a lot of good but you're
also literally in the same process of
ruining millions of lives like
that's
more important yeah i had watched a few
uh minutes of the previous episode it
was a never before seen before they gave
us like all this stuff that actually
been helpful where she's talking about
how like um all of these people who tom
has helped over the years he's paid
tuition for like i got him jobs yes he
was extremely corrupt and stole a lot of
money but apparently he was also
generous towards others right so those
people who experience this generosity
where are they is what she's trying to
say like
but it's just weird to me that she's
divorcing this man because he was so
evil towards her and i was trying so
hard to like make him seem like a good
guy yeah and then the whole conversation
about like you know how sad we are for
tom because he's gonna go to a home like
after this storied life that he's lived
no it's weird i'm just like what about
the widows and orphans they can't even
afford a nurse nothing's making sense
and like erica's just like really trying
to change a narrative and is having a
like it's not doing a good job of it
like at all and her talking points
really seem like they are in
coordination with things that tom might
be saying yeah like
as if they're on the same team so she's
not only walking this line of like i
knew nothing about this and this has
nothing to do with me but also like
defending tom and irena uh kills me to
say made a good point when she said that
erica everyone wants erica to say but
what about the orphans and widows you
know to be so like upset for them but
any
indication that she gives about anything
regarding the case
is
her involving herself in it so she
actually can't say those things yeah so
i can believe that
it's just really hard but i erica did
actually have an honest moment when she
was talking about how like if i'm um you
know too happy then i don't care and
then i understand
my head in shame then i'm guilty and
that i understand and i think we're
watching that all play out the different
like
routes she grabbed she's taking in terms
of defending herself it's just a mess no
and honestly to me the most egregious
thing that was done all episode was done
by kyle do you know what i'm about to
say it was so little it bothered me so
much so they're all sitting after
they're all sitting after the long day
and erica is going on with her woe is me
story and and she's really just like
making herself out to be the victim and
i'm sure sutton has a lot on her mind
but she doesn't say word because her and
eric are not speaking and all the women
are like you're being so funny erica hi
let me lick your butthole and then
kyle's like sudden you're very quiet cat
got your tongue
are you [ __ ] serious now second time
she's taking stuff and throwing her in
front of her boss and said i'm helping
and no one said we're sutton i don't
know like she is the worst [ __ ]
friend and to me that was worse than
what she did at it made something so
uncomfortable something's already so
awkward she's so awkward and also for a
sutton it's like when they're going to
talk about eric's legal woes sutton has
questions
she has been told she can't ask those
questions or or what you know
some can't ask her questions when
they're talking about this so something
has nothing to say because if she's not
allowed to say what she's actually
thinking then what there's nothing to
say exactly kyle if i can suss that out
kyle should be able to know exactly what
she was doing she was not being stupid
yeah no the whole episode was so [ __ ]
lame especially because kathy wasn't
there to get all these women in line
well that was the other thing about the
episode like for a girls trip it was
very piecemeal at many times like kathy
didn't want to go up and then sutton
didn't want to go up like everyone was
just like kind of doing their own thing
i just [ __ ] love kathy like i know
she was so good on watch what happens
live like
and
the episode was annoying because kyle
was still being like so
up erica's ass like
it's hard because kyle's one of my
favorites but all these women
i guess i would say aside from sutton
and garcelle all of them are have been
an enormous disappointment to me yeah i
agree and by the way every time somebody
brings up denise like i literally get
down on my knees and bow down to them no
and i'm so excited that it looks like
next week the season finale you know one
over a year later
is still looking for justice for denise
and like
that i it brings a tear in my eye and
when you do flashbacks of how they
interrogated this poor woman who very
well might have had an extramarital
affair with a woman and you know what
it's not a crime nobody gets hurt and
it's really nobody's business very well
the way they [ __ ] interrogated her
like she stole millions of dollars from
orphans and widows like that's where is
that energy where is a quarter of the
energy maybe if that hadn't happened
last season i would be able to say you
know what these women's not our
businesses clearly just stay above the
line with one another they don't
interrogate each other about all their
legal things yep so
i could i couldn't be okay with it maybe
yeah
but given the context of last season
it's just
so hypocritical it's it's hard to ignore
yeah no it's glaring
gleaming yeah
um but yeah other than that it was a
nice episode watch happens live was good
it was like a pajama pajama party theme
was cute kathy's just everything of the
sort yeah it was really cute kathy was
so cute and um
there's just a lot going on a lot
yeah
what why are you smiling
i don't know it was like
just kind of weird like i liked it i
know i liked it too but first of all i'm
glad that kyle like called out andy in
the clubhouse being so [ __ ] shady
like why are they putting sisters
against each other like why can't they
[ __ ] help themselves just like that
once that was like when someone was on
watching happens live and it was like to
the effect of like whose side are you on
jax or rihanna like
like
that's funny actually
no that's like outrageous like that's
funny it's just
it's all so mean and they're always just
like making fun of the person sitting
there i imagine it's like uncomfortable
yes i agree um
but kathy was super cute and
her presence was it was a gift yeah it
was um and that is our show and it's
also our final show of the week there is
no show tomorrow like we said but we are
back on monday to deliver lots of
goodness so jackie's going to vermont
and i'm going to kailandia
and we're both gonna have an amazing
trip i can't forget my password they
have really
yes strict customs at klandia only the
best only the best that's our show you
guys thank you so much for listening
this week hope you enjoyed all the
episodes if you're looking for more
content tomorrow there are five new
episodes this month on patreon and then
there's also like 200 other ones that
you can watch vlogs podcasts oh yes
right 256. wow thanks
um so check it out patreon.com chose
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast millennial morning show
where we deliver the fast fast stories
that you need to know every monday
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast and
where podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio catbacks all the places
wherever you live in a podcast find out
more until seven five star view about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
we hope you guys have an amazing day and
if you still made it to the end of this
episode congratulations you are now a
member of the society season two full of
true toasters who really listen to the
end of the episodes and to let us know
that you made it here drop an emoji on
our most recent instagram picture maybe
the emoji of the ice cream cone the ice
cream cone because justice for carvel
have an amazing day you guys will see
you on monday bye